this is a production of cornell
university
thank you all for that introduction and
yeah i'm excited to share my work with
everybody on the genetics genome editing
of fiberblade susceptibility genes as a
robust strategy to develop and improve
apple cultivars
so i naturally like to start the
background of my disease i work on fire
blight
um it's caused by the pathogen arwenia
and my lava it's a gram-negative
necrotropic bacteria causes hundreds of
millions of dollars of damage
in the u.s alone and it's been a problem
for hundreds of years
and given its necrotrophic bacteria its
main directive
is to kill as much host tissue as
possible to
feed off the dead material and subsist
off of that
does this in two ways so uh uses a
exopolysaccharide and mlavran
to constrict vascular tissue and
restrict any kind of water or nutrition
to that area of
the plant that's getting infected
and more to the purview of my research
the other method is through a direct
injection
of bacterial affected proteins via the
type 3 secretion system which acts like
a a molecular syringe
that will inject these effectors that
have a multitude of functions
related towards blocking immune
signaling
as well as avoiding host detection you
can see some of the common symptoms on
the
in the image on the right uh we have the
shepherd's crook which is a
bending wilting of the apical meristem
as well as in black from chronic tissue
bacterial ooze which is an exudation of
that exopolysaccharide
uh so given that most of the susceptible
the
cultivars used in production today are
susceptible to fire blight all the fresh
market apples you get in the grocery
store
resistance breeding is in high demand
but with tree breeding that comes with
uh
quite a bit of challenges as well so um
to introduce resistances from wild
species
it can take up to 15 to 25 years and
that's mainly due to high herzegovisi
from being
now crosser and linkage drag and trying
to recover fruit quality
and multiply all that by four to five
year juvenile cycle per
um per round of uh crossing if you were
trying to do
multiple iterations of a back crossing
scheme to a current parent
that can take quite a long time is
infeasible for a lot of
a lot of breeders that just focus on
fruit quality primarily
and on top of that you have
incompatibility where miles domestica
can only really cross with uh the three
main
progenitor species uh as opposed to the
50 or 60
other species that exist um and when
we're breeding for resistance we're
looking
primarily at these mbs llr genes
that are strong triggers and detectors
of the pathogen as well as
elucidators of a strong effect or
triggered immunity in host defense
pathways
so the most characterized one we have is
a mr5 that comes from mal's robusta
and it's a coil coil mbsl uh mbslr gene
uh and with that is is already found to
have strains that overcome that
resistance so
even if you were to accomplish that goal
of breeding resistance into an elite
cultivar
uh with that comes an added selection
pressure to accelerate the
pathogen adaptation and um
ultimately go through this boom and bust
cycle where you can have multiple years
of strong resistance
and then a breakdown in a volatile next
couple of years
and this is where i think uh
susceptibility genes as a breeding
target can really fill in some of those
gaps so we classify it more as a
recessive resistance
given it's it's described better as a
loss of function mutation uh
and we can classify this in certain ways
it's a very broad
uh set of terms instead of targets so
anything that allows for pathogen
compatibility you're facilitating host
assistance going from
a host to a non-host or
encoding negative regulators of immune
signaling
that pathogen can leverage and turn off
immune signaling
and any of those regulatory elements as
well as a sustained compatibility this
could be over multiple years of disease
infection
where the plant could have a certain
structure or
target that fulfills metabolic or
structural needs like a sugar
transporter that is
hijacked by the pathogen and left in an
active conformation
so two quick examples from literature
and then other crops is
cslob1 which is uh done in grapefruit
with conservative citrus
um it's a lateral organ boundaries
domain transcription factor
that is targeted by xanthomonas citri
which is a bacterial disease
and what they found is the knockout of
this gene uh reduced susceptibility with
minimal fitness costs which is one of
the biggest criticisms of susceptibility
genes
um and with os sweet which was found in
rice
and knocked out kind of my example
earlier you have the sugar transporter
that is targeted by santa monica species
from these transcription activator like
effectors
and with the knockout of this gene again
you have reduced susceptibility
and they found no no fitness cost
statistically
so looking at uh my specific genes
in apple they're more disease-specific
so you have hrpn interacting protein of
malice
and you have dsp a slash e interacting
protein and malice hypomandipum
both are transmembrane proteins and both
interact with
their own respective erwenia affected
proteins
and the main goal of the the vector
proteins is to try to
stop any kind of immune signaling well
the main purpose of these transmembrane
proteins
is to try to capture any
signals um early signals of
extracellular
uh molecular patterns of erwinia um to
try to
elucidate out an early defense response
uh well the effector protein tries to
try to block that and inhibit any kind
of downstream pathways
so uh this is since these genes are
conserved across
malice uh we're interested to see what
the genetic variation is across
a diverse set of genotypes so across 93
genotypes in the germplasm inoculated
them all with
fire blight in the greenhouse and
measured their
their lesion length in the chute and in
the leaf and across the total distance
um
and then generated amplicon sequencing
data for each of the eight genes
and with the alignments identified 87
total snip variants
and performed marker trait association
uh just straightforward
wallace each test for each of the snips
you can see on the manhattan plot on the
left
there's a few there's 30 totally unique
snips that had significant effect on the
tree
but two that we highlighted in diaphragm
2b that was found in 2018
2019 um as well as in multiple tissue
types and
multiple traits and diaphragm 4b which
was found in
higher significance for three traits um
and you can see
across multiple years there's a
significant difference in the phenotype
based on the snip class
i'm also interested to see if there's an
additive response to having
a combination of the lower
susceptibility snips and higher
susceptibility steps you can see the
first two columns here
in the box plot this is a combination of
genotype that has
both reduced susceptibility snips and
both increase susceptibility snips
showing the most extreme classes with
intermediate responses for the mixture
um the mixture of the two classes
we also looked at the distribution of
these snips
across um the different species
wild and domesticated that we use in the
study
with the you know basic conclusions
coming out as
the vast majority of males domestica
sessions had increased susceptibility
snips with a few notable
interesting accession exceptions of some
interesting cultivars
and the wild had a mixture of both
susceptible and
increased and decreased susceptibility
that were likely
masked by the resistances that
already exist within those genotypes
so even i were to make really specific
markers uh out of that data
it still comes with a lot of issues that
tree breeding brings so genome editing
is a really promising technique
um to knock out susceptibility genes and
uh produce really nice pre-breeding
lines
or elite cultivars with heritable
mutations
so you could do this via biological
vector with agrobacterium
and have integration of tdna into the
genome
and perform the double strand break
non-homologous end joining
and get that early stop code and then
knocks out the gene but what this ends
up happening is
you have a
regulation you have a
a certain level of regulation that you
have to follow and segregating out that
vector backbone is is not
feasible in tree crops given the long
tube in that cycle
so what i'm working on is a dna free
technique
um using biologic bombardment or
protoplast
where you introduce free and stable
sgrnas and cas9 to perform the same task
but in a dna free manner which is lower
on the regulations and you still get
heritable mutation
and elite cultivar while skipping at
least one reproductive cycle
and this is just some of my work here
i'm targeting diaphragm 4a
hyphen 1b and the genotypes gallon
honeycrisp
via bombardment agrobacterium with an
interest in typing 2b which was from
the previous work i presented and
uh just some validation uh from previous
literature
you can see a knockdown of hyphen 1b
and see the wild type here of galaxy the
cultivar galaxy is very susceptible
and the transgenic explants are
having quite a bit of produced
susceptibility and
more recently you have a christopher
knockout full knockout of
diaper 4a in gala and golden delicious
where you have
susceptible response for both and then
the transgenic plants
have reduced susceptibility and
significant upper growth
which is a good sign so part of my the
interest of my work is to do this in a
dna free manner
test this in different genetic
backgrounds and with
against a diversity of different strains
of bacteria
and to to really test the robustness
possibly with even double mutants of
these genes to see if there's an
additivity that holds up
um similar to the data i presented
earlier
so with that i'd like to thank dr vascon
um some of our lab members giuliani and
della
as well as my funding from ardp and some
of the collaborators on the
genetic variation project um michaela
monoi
diego micheletti and dr villarreal
philly
and with that i'd be happy to take any
questions
anytime i have that
thank you for the wonderful talk ricky
that's really good
um yeah you just you were perfect in
time so we have five minutes for
discussion awesome yeah i am monitoring
the chat for you
yeah i can see the chat so okay
um yeah let me read the question out
loud um
so there's one question from ed he's
saying cool an editing process how did
you control for population structure in
the associate
associations yeah so
um we tested for uh we ran a pca
and noticed uh there wasn't too much
population structure
uh and when utilizing that in the model
given us a small data set there seemed
to be some overfitting in the model so
these were just kind of straightforward
um
wallace park assistant uh arbitrate
associations
um can i go ahead this is jean-luc
um so you talked about these
susceptibility genes that when you knock
them out they
gain resistance without any detrimental
side effect but
like why would a why would a species or
a plant want to keep those around
and i mean i think it's totally possible
maybe they come through
you know they are generally a
deleterious
and you know drifts can bring
deleterious genes to fixation and so on
but
otherwise say there was some beneficial
effect
that you just haven't noticed what would
what would your lead hypothesis be
on the the value of these of these
alleles
yeah so the contribution of keeping the
susceptibility alleles within the plant
is actually really vital given that
a lot of them are associated with
certain basic plant functions
so um in the case of the sugar
transporter that's that's something that
the plant be you know in a regular case
would
would want to keep around uh for
typical functioning um but if we induce
uh that knockout or or some kind of loss
of function mutation
there's enough redundancy in the system
to account for that loss
of that important target while
taking away a major
leverage point for the pathogen to
overcome
any kind of resistances and increase
proliferation and increase the
viability of the environment for it to
proliferate and
perform pathogenesis so um yeah
that's why there's typically um a
i guess like a criticism of
susceptibility genes is like
why would you want to knock out
targets that have basic plant functions
but
what the evidence shows is that you know
there's probably so much redundancy in
the system
or there's likely enough accounting in
these pathways that
you can perform these knockouts to a
certain degree and not see that fitness
cost
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu